vas-y rond c'est dans son appartement
que lalita adhérents du sel à guyancourt
depuis trois ans reçoit lille est
inscrite elle depuis un an et demi les
deux adhérentes ont l'habitude
d'échanger des services
la spécialité de lalita les massages est
ce que tu préfères aujourd'hui jasmin
comme d'habitude ou à monde sinon là
j'ai cette fois ci largo
qu'est ce que tu veux le monde ça va
sentir au sel de guyancourt chacun
possède dès l'inscription 75 points ici
les euros sont bannis et sont remplacés
par des grenouilles
par exemple quelqu'un qui a besoin qu'on
convient de jardiner chez lui et on
demande de l'aide
on met une annonce et en fonction de la
personne qui dit oui j'accepte de vous
couper
j'ai pas de tailler la haie par exemple
pour deux heures en échange vous me
donner ses comptes grenouille si on est
d'accord on négocie le nombre de go no
si on est d'accord on excepte à ce
moment là la personne qui a un jardin
qui avait besoin de cette aide donne ce
conte grenouille à l'autre personne
les adhérents du sel peuvent aussi
échanger en fonction de leur
savoir-faire sans amputer leur nombre de
points lisait à garder la fille de
lalita durant plusieurs jours après
l'école le massage ne l'écoutera donc
aucune grenouille ce soit comme on vit
dans une société de consommation moi ce
qui m'a vraiment attiré dans un premier
temps c'était voilà tout est recyclé va
la table qui est parti et qui voulaient
partir à la poubelle de les récupérer et
puis le la bibliothèque et puis voilà
donc on ne gaspille rien quand je dis
par exemple dans ma famille a une
nouvelle robe gm à côté une grenouille
le concept séduit de plus en plus par
ces temps de crise les yvelines compte
actuellement 900
ouais enfin dit